OK, let's unpack this.
Imagine something as well as
universally wholesome as
fundamentally American as well
as mom and apple pie.
Right.
For generations, that phrase it
evoked warmth, tradition, a
strong sense of shared identity.
In America, it felt like
something utterly
unquestionable, didn't it?
Oh, absolutely.
A symbol of comfort.
And a common language for
belonging that just seemed well
beyond reproach.
It truly was a cultural
touchstone.
Yeah, kind of a default setting
for what was considered good,
foundational and, you know,
widely accepted.
It suggested a certain bedrock
of shared values that, for the
most part, people generally
didn't dispute.
Exactly.
But here's where it gets really
interesting and frankly, a bit
disorienting.
Today, in certain contexts, that
exact phrase mom and apple pie
can be interpreted as coded
language, coded for oppression,
even something described as
fascist.
It's quite a leap.
You heard that right.
How do we go from wholesome to
controversial to something
deemed problematic so
dramatically and it feels like,
so quickly?
It's a profound and yeah,
accelerating shift, isn't it?
And this deep dive, it's all
about exploring precisely that
phenomenon, how the redefinition
seemingly ordinary traditional
life and its symbols as
oppressive is profoundly
reshaping our culture, How it's
fueling significant backlash and
critically eroding trust in
established institutions.
And where are we drawing this
from?
What's the basis for this
analysis?
Yeah, good question.
We're drawing our insights today
from a pretty comprehensive
analysis.
It pulls together a recent
sociological studies, cultural
commentary, observations of
public sentiment, basically
material that really dives into
the undercurrents of these
shifts, trying to map out what's
happening beneath the surface
debates.
OK, got it.
So our mission today is to
unpack this often perplexing,
sometimes jarring
transformation, right?
We'll delve into what happens
when once unquestionable symbols
become, well, divisive
battlegrounds, sparking intense
debate and, you know, real world
consequences.
And we'll explore that inherent
human response, that pushback
you get when people feel
controlled or shamed.
Yeah, that resistance and then
crucially, the tangible outcomes
playing out in our daily lives.
I mean, think about it from the
brands you choose at the grocery
store all the way up to public
policy debates.
It touches everything.
It really does.
What does it mean for us when
the very ground beneath our
shared understanding shifts so
dramatically?
And why do something some
symbols stubbornly endure
despite immense pressure to
change?
Or, you know, just discard them.
It's a complex and layered
reality, definitely and.
We're going to try and unravel
it together, so let's cast our
minds back a bit, shall we?
Think about those earlier
decades, maybe reflecting the
broad cultural consensus of,
say, the 1980s and 1990's, the
phrase as American as mom and
apple pie.
It wasn't just a quaint saying,
was it?
No, not at all.
It was a straightforward
description.
It immediately brought to mind
something wholesome, comforting,
universally accepted.
It symbolized warmth, tradition,
a strong sense of shared
identity.
It felt utterly neutral.
Almost.
Yeah, above reproach, like a
default setting for American
life.
That's right.
This wasn't merely an idiom.
It really encapsulated a common
societal understanding of what
was good, foundational, and,
well, unquestionable.
Exactly.
It represented A perceived
normal baseline for many
Americans.
A cultural bedrock, if you will,
that people generally agreed
upon without much contention,
right?
It was like a shorthand for a
kind of idealized comfortable
existence that most people maybe
aspired to or at least
recognized as a positive shared
ideal.
You can almost taste it, can't
you?
Think of those sepia tone
memories perhaps?
Or maybe those Norman Rockwell
paintings?
Yeah, the classic imagery.
Not just idyllic scenes of
family gatherings or kids
playing baseball, but almost a
visual shorthand for a
particular kind of American
dream.
Uncomplicated, warm, and, you
know, universally positive.
Definitely.
These images, like the phrase
itself, were widely seen as
benign, positive, and truly
representative of a shared
cultural heritage that
supposedly brought people
together.
They weren't seen as having a
hidden agenda or a problematic
past, right?
Just pure, wholesome Americana.
Exactly.
These were the images that
permeated advertising, political
rhetoric, popular culture,
reinforcing that sense of a
unified sort of uncomplicated
national identity.
Indeed, they were the visual and
linguistic shorthand for a
collective sense of American
identity and values.
They were presented and widely
accepted as common ground.
Yeah, common crowd.
A point of unity that seemed
almost beyond critique.
And this consensus, it allowed
for certain stability, a shared
understanding of what it meant
to be part of the culture, even
amidst other disagreements.
So we've charted that dramatic
shift in how these seemingly
innocent symbols are perceived
now.
But what happens when that
perceived neutrality is just
shattered, right?
And when these very symbols that
once united us were released,
weren't divisive, suddenly come
under intense scrutiny or even
outright attack?
Yeah.
Prompting this fundamental
questioning of their very
essence.
That's precisely where we enter
the current landscape of
redefinition.
It's a key theme in the analysis
we're drawing from.
Modern cultural critics are now
actively reinterpreting these
traditional symbols, Things like
the nuclear family, traditional
expressions of faith, the
idealized small town.
Even baseball.
Even seemingly innocent pastimes
like baseball or the concept of
domestic life itself.
They're arguing that these
symbols, far from being neutral,
actually carry histories.
Histories of exclusion,
patriarchy, privilege, and under
this new lens, the cultural
consensus of prior decades.
That normal baseline we just
discussed?
It's no longer viewed as benign
or neutral.
OK, So what is it viewed as?
Instead, it's explicitly framed
as a structure of dominance.
Wow.
That's a very strong assertion.
So just to unpack that, if
you're just living your life,
maybe doing what your parents
did or holding on to these
traditional symbols because they
resonate with your personal
identity or you know your
heritage, you're now told you're
participating in systems of
racism, sexism, homophobia,
transphobia, and white
supremacy.
That's the implication, yeah.
It sounds like a very strong
assertion to say there is no
neutral ground.
As our analysis points out, for
you listening, this might feel
quite disorienting.
Does the analysis delve into why
this perspective became so
prominent, or explore the roots
of this reinterpretation beyond
just stating its outcome?
It does, yeah.
This term structure of
dominance, which emerges from
various critical social
theories, suggests that what was
once perceived as universal or
benign actually function to
uphold existing power
imbalances.
OK.
It implies that these cultural
norms implicitly benefited
dominant groups, often
historically white, male,
heterosexual, while
marginalizing or disadvantaging
others.
So the idea is that even if it
wasn't intended maliciously.
Exactly.
It's an assertion that even
seemingly innocuous cultural
elements, by defining what is
normal or ideal, contribute to
systemic inequalities, and that
there's no way to opt out of
that system without actively
dismantling it.
Wow.
This perspective argues that the
very innocence of mom and apple
pie was a form of soft power
subtly enforcing a particular
worldview.
Wow.
So no more just enjoying a
quaint painting or a simple
phrase.
This perspective asserts that if
this starting point for this
reinterpretation is that
America's traditions are
inherently fascist or deeply
flawed, then suddenly even
expressing something as benign
as nostalgia for Norman Rockwell
paintings because the problem.
That's the logic, yes.
This perspective asserts that
the only safe position, the only
morally justifiable stance, is
full alignment with the newest
standards, standards which are
often dictated by what our
analysis describes as the most
radical voices in the cultural
conversation.
Right.
It's like a litmus test for
cultural purity, almost.
Exactly.
The pressure becomes intense to
adopt these new definitions, to
self police one's language and
associations, and to publicly
disavow the old normal.
That sounds stressful.
It creates an environment where
fear of misinterpretation or
accusation can lead to self
censorship, and that profoundly
impacts public discourse and
individual expression.
It leaves very little room for
nuance or personal
interpretation, effectively
shrinking the space for open
dialogue.
So for you listening, this
raises A crucial question.
How does this radical
reinterpretation impact how we
understand our past, or even how
we express personal identity in
daily conversations?
What does it feel like when
things you once considered
harmless or simply part of your
heritage are suddenly labeled as
problematic or even oppressive?
It really changes the ground
rules for how we navigate our
culture, doesn't it?
Adding layers of complicity to
interactions that maybe used to
feel simple.
It absolutely does.
And this brings us to a really
fundamental point about human
nature, a principle that
underpins much of what we're
observing.
The underlying belief that words
and laws alone can fundamentally
remake human behavior.
Well, it often ignores something
basic and deeply ingrained.
As our analysis clearly states,
people resist when they feel
controlled.
They defy when they feel shamed.
And this isn't just, you know,
know, an anecdotal observation.
It taps into well established
psychological principle.
Precisely.
This isn't about logic
necessarily.
It's an inherent, almost primal
response.
This is where concepts like
reactance theory come into play,
right?
Exactly.
When individuals perceive that
their freedom of choice, their
autonomy, or their expression is
being threatened or removed,
they experience an immediate,
often unconscious, drive to
restore that freedom.
It's like trying to hold on to
sand, yeah.
It's like trying to squeeze
water with your bare hands.
It just slips through your
fingers, often with more force
than before.
External pressure, while it can
be effective at enforcing
outward compliance.
Yeah, you can make people follow
rules.
Right, but it's so often
backfires when attempting to
shift deeply held internal
convictions or aspects of
identity, such as cultural
heritage or personal values.
You can try to police language,
pass new rules, demand outward
conformity, but genuine belief
that can't be forced through
fear or shame.
That's a crucial distinction.
And if we look at historical
attempts to suppress cultural
practices or beliefs, think of
prohibitions on certain
languages, religious practices,
traditions.
They've often LED not to
eradication but to covert
resistance, or, perhaps more
paradoxically, to a
strengthening of resolve and a
deeper embrace among those
targeted.
Right, the forbidden fruit
effect.
Almost.
Exactly.
The more you push against
something deeply held, the more
resilient and cherished it can
become, sometimes transforming
into a symbol of defiance
itself.
It's an inverse effect where the
pressure applied actually
reinforces the very thing it
seeks to diminish.
And this inherent human tendency
to resist coercion, to push back
against what feels like an
imposed redefinition, that's the
wellspring, isn't it?
That's the source of this
significant counter movement
that we're seeing play out
today.
It's what drives a lot of the
backlash we observe from quiet
discontent all the way to very
public actions.
This isn't just theory, it's
manifesting daily.
This fundamental resistance
explains why backlash has become
so incredibly common and in many
cases so potent.
When people feel cornered, when
they feel their identity or what
they hold dear is being
attacked, especially if they
perceive it as an unfair or
ideological assault, they find
ways to push back.
And often this starts with what
our analysis calls small,
spiteful choices.
Small, spiteful choices.
That phrase really sticks with
you, doesn't it?
It does.
It's not always about taking to
the streets or organizing huge
rallies.
At least not at first.
No, it's more subtle sometimes.
These choices can be as simple
yet cumulatively powerful as
where individuals spend their
money.
You know, deciding to
consciously avoid or patronize
certain brands.
Or how they.
Vote, or how they vote in local
elections, choosing candidates
who maybe resist these cultural
shifts or even what causes they
choose to support or just as
importantly, avoid on principle,
right these individual actions
when aggregated, when multiplied
across millions of people who
feel similarly, they build into
larger, much more visible
movements.
Movements that can send powerful
economic and political signals.
And our analysis highlights
those widely publicized boycotts
of brands like, say, Bud Light
or Target as crime examples of
this phenomenon.
Yeah, those are huge.
Stories and these boycotts As
the analysis meticulously
explains, we're not only about
beer or clothing.
This is a crucial distinction
that often gets missed in the
sort of surface level media
coverage.
OK, So what were they about
then?
They were in in essence signals,
signals of resistance to a
broader cultural order that
insists everything once
considered normal is now
suspect.
They represented A broader, more
profound rejection of a cultural
narrative that felt imposed,
that felt like an ideological
mandate rather than an organic
shift in public opinion.
It was a refusal to conform, a
reclaiming of agency through
consumer power.
What's truly fascinating here,
and quite ironic, is the
profound impact of this
pressure.
The very attempt to discard old
symbols, to declare them
problematic or even oppressive.
It actually transforms them into
new icons of rebellion.
Think about it.
Mom and apple pie, once just
simple and comforting, are now
for some highly charged
political statement.
It's a complete inversion.
It is.
They don't just survive because
they're perfect or because
they're universally good, but
because they are stubborn, like
the people who hold on to them
when told they must let go.
It's almost a defiant act of
cultural preservation, a re
embracing of what's being
rejected.
That stubbornness, that deep
seated human desire for autonomy
and self preservation is indeed
key.
And this section offers you, the
listener, a really important
framework for understanding
seemingly irrational consumer
behaviors or unexpected
political shifts, right?
It shows you how attempts to
control cultural narratives can
inadvertently strengthen the
very things they seek to
dismantle, often through the
quiet, persistent and often
stubborn will of individuals.
It's a powerful reminder that
culture isn't just a top down
phenomenon dictated by
institutions or academics.
It's a living, breathing entity
shaped by countless individual
choices and resistances from the
ground up.
So we've talked about these big,
sweeping cultural shifts and the
broad human tendency to resist.
But sometimes a single incident
can serve as a perfect
microcosm.
Yeah, like a case study.
Exactly of just how far this
redefinition of normal has gone,
and how quickly everyday things
can become cultural flashpoints.
Enter the Sydney Sweeney
controversy.
Yes, the jeans at.
American Eagle, the clothing
brand.
They released an ad featuring
the actress Sydney Sweeney with
the slogan Sydney Sweeney has
great jeans.
I mean, on the surface it's a
simple, lighthearted punt,
right?
Great genes, as in denim pants.
And great genes and.
Great genes as in genetic
traits?
Seems like a classic advertising
word play.
Pretty standard stuff.
That was certainly the apparent
intent, a straightforward,
playful advertisement designed
to be memorable.
However, the contemporary
cultural landscape is now so,
well, hypersensitive.
Yeah, that's one word for it.
And so attuned to perceived
ideological subtexts that
critics quickly claimed the word
play promoted eugenics.
Eugenics.
Really.
Yes, this accusation was
specifically leveled because
Sydney Sweeney is blonde and
blue eyed, characteristics that
some link to historical eugenic
ideals of quote ideal Aryan
features.
Wow.
So a simple jeans ad because of
a pun and an actress's
appearance suddenly becomes
fascist coded, exclusionary, and
racially insensitive.
That's not just a leap, it's a
pole vault into a completely
different interpretive universe
for what many would consider
just a benign piece of
advertising.
It makes you wonder what, if
anything, is safe from this kind
of reinterpretation anymore.
It is indeed a remarkable
reinterpretation, of course.
Others vigorously defended the
ad, dismissing the outrage as
absurd and a clear overreaction
right, arguing that it was a
deliberate misreading of a
simple marketing ploy.
What's particularly telling
about this incident, though, and
an important insight from our
analysis, is the outcome.
OK, what happened?
Despite the significant
controversy, American Eagle
sales actually rose.
They rose.
Rose and its stock went up.
This suggests that the outrage,
rather than deterring consumers,
may have inadvertently drawn
more attention and even garnered
loyalty from those who felt the
criticism was unwarranted or
part of an overreaching cultural
critique.
That is truly surprising, and it
speaks volumes about the current
state of our public discourse,
doesn't it?
Really does.
This incident vividly
illustrates just how fragile
cultural space has become.
As our analysis puts it, even a
seemingly innocuous ad about
genes can trigger accusations of
Nazi propaganda or systemic
bias.
The implication is crystal
clear.
Under these conditions,
everything is political.
Nothing is safe from
reinterpretation.
It's like walking through a
minefield where the rules keep
changing and any step can
trigger an unforeseen explosion
of criticism.
It creates A pervasive sense of
caution and anxiety and public
expression for.
Sure.
And this incident, along with
its surprising financial
outcome, it reveals a new
frontier in marketing, doesn't
it?
It highlights how certain
strategies, even accidental
ones, can play directly into
these cultural tensions, often
with unintended but apparently
profitable results.
It's a powerful lesson in how
outrage itself can be monetized,
in a way.
So what's truly fascinating here
is the role of what's being
called extreme marketing.
Modern advertising often thrives
on provocation.
This isn't just about being edgy
or cool.
Extreme marketing deliberately
uses shock, exaggeration and
controversy to cut through the
incredible noise of the modern
world.
Right, you have to stand out
somehow.
Exactly.
In a landscape saturated with
content, a vanilla ad simply
gets lost.
The goal is to trigger strong
emotions, whether positive or
negative, aiming to make
campaigns memorable, not just
likable or easily forgotten.
It's about igniting
conversation.
Even if that conversation is a
heated debate, that's the point.
And while the American Eagle ad
may not have been intentionally
designed as extreme marketing
from the outset.
Right.
Maybe he was just a pun.
Maybe.
But it certainly functioned
precisely like one of these
campaigns.
It effectively generated both
outrage and loyalty
simultaneously, dramatically
amplifying its reach far beyond
what a safe or uncontroversial
ad could ever achieve.
Our analysis notes that outrage
spreads faster than approval,
especially on social media
platforms, and controversy
inherently makes ads memorable.
It ensures they dominate
conversations, whether those
conversations are positive,
negative, or a mixture of both.
This virality, even if negative
in tone, translates into
eyeballs and often, as we saw,
sales.
But this strategy, whether
intentional or accidental, it
comes with a significant cost
and this is a critical take away
I think.
Definitely.
Each time companies lean into
provocation, and we're seeing it
happen more and more frequently,
they deepen the cultural divide.
They pour fuel on the fire.
Exactly.
They transform their products
into political signals, forcing
consumers into a kind of binary
choice.
They actively invite the public
to fight their battles through
consumer choices.
It's no longer just about
selling a product or a
lifestyle.
It's about selling a side, a
stance in an ongoing cultural
conflict.
You're asked to pick a team with
your wallet.
And this creates a powerful and
often unsettling feedback loop.
It means every purchase feels
like a vote in an ongoing war
over meaning.
This fundamentally changes the
nature of consumerism, elevating
everyday transactions into overt
political statements.
What you buy or don't buy
becomes a public declaration of
your values and your alignment
in the culture wars.
That sounds exhausting.
It puts a burden on the consumer
to constantly consider the
political implications of their
purchasing decisions, turning a
trip to the store into an
ideological act.
So you are now navigating a
world where even buying a
particular brand of soda or a
pair of jeans can be interpreted
as taking a side in a larger
cultural conflict.
This section really helps you
understand why brands might
participate in this, whether on
purpose or by accident, and what
the broader societal
consequences are.
It's a whole new layer of
complexity to shopping, isn't
it?
It really is.
The marketplace itself has
become an extension of the
ideological battleground.
OK, so if we expand our view
beyond individual consumer
choices and advertising, we see
that the way language is used,
especially highly charged
ideological language, has
direct, profound implications
for policy.
Right, it's not just words.
Exactly when, for instance, law
enforcement is described not
merely as flawed or imperfect,
which most people would agree
with, but as inherently fascist.
Or, you know, using freezes.
Like all cops are kidnappers.
The perceived logical response
to such a strong ideological
claim is often framed as well.
We must dismantle them.
The rhetoric directly informs
the proposed solution.
It's a Direct Line, isn't it?
From a powerful rhetorical claim
to a concrete policy suggestion,
almost like a syllogism for
social change.
It is.
And the underlying idea for
proponents of such a view is
that removing this perceived
source of oppression will, by
definition, create safety and
freedom for marginalized
communities.
Makes.
Sense from their perspective.
However, our analysis argues,
and we've seen evidence of this
in various places, that the
result is often the exact
opposite.
How so?
When law enforcement is treated
as an enemy where its
capabilities are intentionally
diminished, a vacuum is created,
and that vacuum is then filled
by those willing to exploit it.
It's a classic case of
unintended consequences.
OK, can you give an example?
Well, we see this playing out
vividly with specific examples
such as the evolution of
sanctuary cities.
Now, these policies were
initially intended with clearly
stated humanitarian goals as
safe havens for vulnerable
undocumented population.
Right, protecting them from
federal immigration enforcement.
Exactly.
Yet our analysis observes they
can sometimes inadvertently
become targets for predators
precisely because the very
mechanisms of conventional
enforcement are seen as
antagonistic or are
intentionally suppressed within
those areas.
So the protection has a
downside.
And this outcome, surprisingly,
is not just anecdotal.
It's actually quite predictable
through a foundational principle
of game theory.
That's fascinating.
Can you elaborate on the game
theory aspect?
For many, game theory might
sound complex, kind of academic.
Sure, let's simplify it.
In game theory, we analyze how
rational actors make decisions
in strategic situations based on
perceived incentives and
potential outcomes.
Think of it like this.
If a policy effectively signals
a reduced risk of enforcement
for certain activities, in this
case maybe a lower chance of
being apprehended for certain
illicit behaviors within these
designated safe zones, it
changes the payoff matrix for
those seeking to exploit the
system.
It makes it more attractive for
the bad guys.
In a sense, yes.
As our source puts it
beautifully, when an environment
is seen as a city of doves,
Hawks thrive.
The perceived lack of
consequences acts as a powerful
incentive, drawing in those who
would capitalize on the reduced
risk, often to the detriment of
the vulnerable populations the
policy aim to protect.
So it's a cold, calculated
outcome driven by incentives,
not necessarily intentions.
Exactly.
And it's important to note how
this plays out culturally and
geographically.
People living outside these
areas, particularly in, say
suburban and rural communities,
they observe these developments
from a distance.
They often feel insulated from
these specific consequences,
maybe emphasizing their armed
and self reliant nature, and
they express deep skepticism
about these policies and the
underlying ideological
frameworks that drive them.
How is their attitude described?
Their attitude is described in
our analysis as detached, almost
clinical, like watching a slow
moving fire as they quietly
predict when the policies will
fail.
Wow.
There's a palpable sense of
waiting for the inevitable, a
quiet observation of an
unfolding social experiment.
And this detached observation,
combined with the practical
realities of urban governance,
it leads us to a truly
fascinating paradox, doesn't it,
within the very policies meant
to provide refuge and
protection.
Yes, there is a significant
paradox here that the analysis
highlights.
Sanctuary policies explicitly
designed to shield undocumented
immigrants can inadvertently
create concentrations of the
very people federal agencies
seek to remove or detain.
It's a bit like a fishing net
that, while meant to protect
certain fish from being caught
by predators, instead funnels
them into a single, predictable
location.
So it makes enforcement easier
potentially.
What's surprising to many, but
logical from an enforcement
perspective, is that the result
is often that enforcement
becomes easier, not harder, to
authorities.
These cities effectively become
stocked ponds.
Stocked up ponds, I like that.
Where operations are more
efficient precisely because
targets are gathered where they
believe they are safe from
capture, the very concentration
that was supposed to offer
security inadvertently creates a
tactical advantage for those
seeking to enforce federal law.
This creates an incredibly
complex dynamic then,
particularly for city leaders
who are caught between their
stated ideals and the practical
demands of governance.
Publicly, they locally condemn
federal actions against
undocumented immigrants,
upholding the sanctuary ethos.
Right, they have to maintain
that image.
But privately, our analysis
reveals they often engage in
quiet back channel cooperation
with federal authorities to
prevent lawlessness from
spiraling out of control.
The source explicitly states no
mayor wants lawlessness to
spiral out of control.
Of course not.
Therefore, back channel
arrangements keep order behind
the scenes even while public
statements claim resistance.
This reveals a deep tension
where the sanctuary is a sign of
values, but it depends on the
power it opposes.
A delicate dance.
A very delicate dance between
idealism and pragmatism, public
image and private necessity.
And this isn't just about law
enforcement and immigration, is
it?
The broader economic
implications are significant,
too.
Hugely significant businesses
also notice these shifts and the
resulting disorder that can
arise from weakened enforcement
or altered social contracts.
Large retailers, for instance,
are increasingly closing stores
in cities experiencing rising
theft, organized retail crime
and general disorder.
They're making cold, hard
business decisions.
They leave because, quite
simply, survival comes before
politics.
Their departure has tangible
negative effects that ripple
through the entire community.
Like what?
It weakens local economies,
reduces tax revenue and erodes
the very services these policies
were meant to protect.
So what starts as an idealistic
policy driven by strong moral
convictions can have very real
negative economic and social
consequences for the very
communities it aims to help.
Creating a spiral of decline
that affects everyone, including
the most vulnerable.
Precisely, it highlights a
fundamental limitation of
policies rooted purely in
ideals, without sufficient
practical power to enforce them
independently or foresee their
full complex consequences in the
real world.
Indeed, in many ways, our
analysis notes, sanctuary cities
resemble United Nations
resolutions.
That's an interesting
comparison.
How so?
Well, they are very effective at
declaring ideals and moral
stances.
They state what should be what
they believe is morally right,
but they crucially lack
enforcement capabilities of
their own.
They can pass resolutions, but
they can't send in peacekeepers
without external support.
Right.
Precisely.
They inherently rely on the
cooperation of stronger external
powers, and can only truly work
when the larger system allows
them to.
Like the UN, they project moral
authority without the ability to
back it up.
This makes them more about image
than reality.
So they're statements.
They fundamentally survive as
statements, not as structures
capable of independent
enforcement or long term
stability in the face of counter
pressures.
Their existence depends on the
tolerance or even the strategic
calculations of the very
entities they publicly oppose.
This detailed case study invites
you listening to consider the
real world effectiveness of
policies driven purely by
ideology, and how their stated
intentions can often diverge
dramatically from their
practical consequences,
ultimately impacting local
economies, public safety, and
the well-being of the
populations they claim to serve
in ways that might not have been
anticipated.
It's a powerful reminder that
good intentions don't always
translate into good outcomes.
Definitely not.
So if we take a step back now
and look at all the dynamics
we've discussed today, the
redefinition of normal, the
backlash, the profound impact on
everything from individual
consumer choices to the, you
know, intricate details of
public policy, they're not just
isolated incidents, are they?
Our analysis reveals they're
deeply interconnected.
They form a continuous, almost
self feeding cycle that
continues to shape our society.
Yeah, what's truly fascinating
here is how the analysis
meticulously outlines this loop.
It's almost like a feedback
mechanism that just keeps
reinforcing itself.
OK, break it down.
It begins with the redefinition
of normal life is oppressive,
which immediately creates
resentment among those who feel
their identity or way of life is
being unjustly attacked.
Right, that initial spark.
That resentment, in turn,
doesn't just dissipate, it fuels
backlash, manifesting in various
forms of resistance we talked
about.
The pushback.
This backlash then further fuels
polarization, hardening existing
divisions and making compromise
much more difficult.
Driving people further apart.
Then policies shaped purely by
ideology rather than pragmatism
often create chaos, as we saw
with some of those unintended
consequences.
The sanctuary city example.
This chaos then forces quiet
compromises that expose the
limits of the ideology,
revealing where pure idealism
clashes with practical reality.
Back channel deals.
Exactly.
And then the cycle repeats,
often gaining momentum with each
iteration.
It's a powerful and
dispassionate observation of a
societal pattern.
It's like a perpetual motion
machine of conflict, isn't it?
It feels that way sometimes.
The analysis emphasizes that
this observation is driven by no
passion, only the recognition of
patterns in human behavior and
societal responses.
It's a cool, clinical look at a
powerful, repeating dynamic
that's playing out all around
us, often unnoticed in its
cyclical nature.
It's not about assigning blame.
No, It's about understanding the
mechanics of cultural change and
resistance and this recurring
cycle, this predictable pattern.
It's rooted in something truly
fundamental and perhaps
unchangeable about who we are as
humans.
OK, It speaks to the deep
currents of human nature that
precede and often override
ideological constructs.
At the heart of this cycle is
the enduring truth that humans
resist control.
It's almost an instinct, isn't
it?
A core part of our psychological
makeup.
It seems to be.
They will always find ways to
say no, whether that resistance
is quiet and subtle, like those
small spiteful consumer choices
we talked about, or openly
defiant, like large scale
boycotts.
Words and laws certainly have
the power to bend behavior.
They can influence actions,
compel outward compliance, and
shape social norms.
Sure, they have an effect.
But they fundamentally cannot
change the deeper occurrence of
human nature.
You can mandate our behavior,
but you cannot mandate deeply
held belief, identity, or that
innate desire for autonomy.
That's much harder, if not
impossible.
And this conflict between top
down redefinition and bottom up
human nature is likened in our
analysis to an old silent film
gag, which is just a brilliant
analogy.
Oh.
Yeah, what's the analogy?
Cause cigar is lit, everyone
smiles, and the spark slowly
burns toward the explosion.
The audience, aware of human
nature and these predictable
patterns, knows what is coming,
even if the actors pretend they
do not.
Right, you see it coming a mile
away.
And when the inevitable blows,
those who warned about it, those
who recognize these patterns,
will not gloat.
They will simply nod and say it
was always going to happen.
It speaks to an underlying
predictability of human
response, a kind of tragic
inevitability when fundamental
human tendencies are ignored.
It really does the.
Powerful, almost predictive
statement about where we're
headed, or perhaps where we
already are.
The analysis explicitly states
that attempts to control culture
through moral pressure and
redefinition will not end the
way their advocates expect.
In fact, it asserts, the
backlash is already here, in
quiet choices, empty
storefronts, and the erosion of
trust in institutions that have
pushed these redefinitions.
It's not a future prediction.
It's a present reality, visible
and countless small and large
ways every day.
Ultimately, the old symbols of
America, including that very
phrase we started with mom and
apple pie, they endure.
They stick around.
They don't endure because
they're flawless, or because
they represent some perfect
utopia, or because they are
immune to critical examination.
They endure because they are
human.
They are stubborn.
They remain.
They connect with something
deeper than fleeting ideological
trends.
And that's a powerful final
reaffirmation, isn't it?
Mom and apple pie remain, too,
Not as propaganda, not as
dominance, but as things people
quietly hold onto when
everything else is called into
question.
It highlights the deep human
need for connection to
tradition, for familiar
comforts, and for symbols that
anchor identity even amidst
profound societal upheaval and
relentless pressure to discard
them.
Yeah, for you, this section
offers a powerful, almost
predictive framework for
understanding current societal
tensions.
It suggests that deeply
ingrained human tendencies, like
the resistance to control and
the desire to hold onto identity
will always play a significant,
perhaps even decisive, role in
how cultural shifts ultimately
play out.
Often in surprising ways that
defy expectations.
Exactly.
Hashtag #outro.
So we've taken a deep dive into
a truly fascinating and, yeah,
sometimes unsettling cultural
phenomenon today.
The redefinition of common, even
cherished symbols like mom and
apple pie.
From universal comforts to
contentious cultural
flashpoints.
And we've seen how this
redefinition sparks powerful,
often unexpected resistance and
backlash playing out everywhere,
from your everyday consumer
choices to the nuanced details
of city policies.
It's truly interwoven into the
fabric of our lives now, isn't
it, shaping our interactions and
decisions in subtle yet profound
ways.
Our key insights for you
included exploring the
psychological limits of
attempting to command and
control human belief, the
surprising ways modern marketing
can inadvertently intensify
cultural divides.
Yeah, the Jeans edge.
And the often unintended
consequences of ideologically
driven policies that maybe
prioritize values over practical
outcomes.
Perhaps most importantly, we've
touched upon the enduring and
stubborn nature of certain human
values and symbols, how they
persist despite immense pressure
to change or discard them.
They show a remarkable
resilience rooted in something
deeply human that defies easy
redefinition.
So true.
This deep dive reveals A
fundamental truth.
I think about human nature and
societal dynamics.
So as you go about your day, how
might understanding these cycles
and the human tendency to resist
control change how you interpret
headlines?
Or engage with cultural debates.
Or even make your own choices.
Exactly.
In a world constantly trying to
redefine itself, what are the
unexpected sources of resilience
for ideas and symbols?
And what do you quietly hold
onto when everything else is
called into question?
We hope this deep dive has given
you some new perspectives to
ponder and navigate the
complexities of our shared
cultural landscape.